i'm sending jd to the super bowl you
know the bengals are his team the kid
lives and dies for him so i want you to
bring him up in the booth let him do a
little uh commentary you imagine how
that's clear
yeah a little color jd how's it going
[Laughter]
i could just picture it it'd be great
it'd be recorded for all time we bring
jd up in the booth can you imagine if
there was a giant raiding spike like
140 million
that'd be fantastic jd where are you jd
come on without and we'll pretend that
we're at the super bowl and al's going
to throw it here al's going to ask you
what you think and you're going to
respond here we go i'll go ahead
okay jd okay so the the bengals they
bracketed cooper cup that left band
jefferson opened he got free down the
right sideline your take
well you know uh
uh eli apple uh did good uh covering him
and uh you know von bell uh was able to
see uh what uh was looking at the the
eyes of uh uh
i'm trying to think of
matthew stafford and uh you know sam
hover was able to get in there and get
the sack so there you go we'll be right
back after these measures
al do you get the sense the ratings are
plummeting unbelievable